hey started World Economic Forum in
Davos Switzerland Wendy bockelman asked
the question so what do you wanna be
remembered for to the meeting so I'm
gonna need a couple topics here but one
big themes personalized medicine they
talked about this is a very different
way you may expand it turns out that
twenty percent of all the drugs that we
take types are the treatments we give
ourselves twenty percent time I will try
to lose weight we're doing the wrong
thing because although genetically we
look similar to each other we're not the
same we got these things called single
nucleotide polymorphism sniffs SNP's and
may make that big difference or some of
us will take cats for example an
intestinal system we've rub the much
faster so we fatty food we gain weight
other folks have problems other kinds of
foods some of the medications would give
like aspirin no such a common med but
turns out that about a quart of the
population is resistant to the effect of
this so your look at this at a broad
level the reality is that about a fifth
of all the medications we give patients
and I'm a doctor and get a lot of
medications out are not the right rubs
for them if you guys you figure out how
they react for example to a blood
thinner you can reduce complications by
a huge amount it's a lot of the catch of
drugs we use are for the wrong reasons
because the cancers are made they have
the same name but they actually should
get treated different so it's like being
colorblind not all of us are colorblind
if you already got do things a little
different so I give you a little quiz no
test can all do now the next time you
have in the meal I want your dad will be
a small little pink packets saccharine
packets your sweet'n lows and you want
to take that little packet sweet and low
and pour it into a little Bowl water but
as much as you have room for a tennis
ball so like you know I have a couple
two thirds of a cup and then mix it
around and then taste it put a little
bit your mouth if it tastes sweet means
you're a hyper taster supertaster means
you taste a lot of stuff and you know
you actually that's something that is
it's interesting because it predicts
them some of the problems may have like
polyps in your call if it tastes bitter
to you then your super taster so maybe
clear yet if it's bitter your super
taster it doesn't taste that sweet your
Undertaker Undertaker eat more foods to
make their taste buds supertasters don't
like these bitter foods and vegetables
you eat less of them to get colon pops
simple test to figure out something you
may not have thought of before and it
exemplifies how you're different from
everybody else on the planet